Hi, I'm Bill.
Hi Bill, Robert.
Nice to meet you.
Hey, congratulations on being the Teacher of the Year.
Thank you very much, appreciate it.
So, what kind of things do you teach?
I teach family and consumer sciences and leadership.
What we're going to do today is, we're going to use the legs, the wings and the thighs...
...for barbecue chicken, oven baked.
We start with the whole chicken because it is cheaper to buy a whole chicken,...
...cut it into pieces yourself and you can get a lot more out of it.
What we're going to do next is season the chicken,...
...get it on the pan and then to the oven to cook.
So to season it, we've got some black pepper,...
... we've got salt, cinnamon and allspice.
And some ground mustard.
So we've got everything.
So we've got, except that one.
Let's not do too much.
That's okay.
You've just got some extra salt.
I like mine salty.
That's totally fine.
And then we're just kind of evenly sprinkle the spices onto the chicken.
Feels like a chef thing to do.
Absolutely.
We'll let those cook for a little while,...
...we'll baste them with some sauce later.
I think we're going to take a minute to baste some sauce on our chicken.
I like sauce.
That's really good.
Hey, thanks for coming.
It's pretty inspiring to hear what you do.
This is a first for me.
I might surprise my family and show them I know how to do it.
That was fantastic.
That's awesome.
Thanks for having me.
Appreciate it.